[Müzik]
Benim ismim Beritan zorkan Arık Yaklaşık
15 yıldır insanlara hitap ediyorum çok
sayıda Nazım acunnesine katıldım aynı
zamanda bunu meslek olarak da icra
etmeye karar verdim ve belki de en çok
bağdaştırabileceğiniz mesleklerden bir
tanesi olan avukatlık mesleğini önerdim
bugün
Cosmos teması içerisinde belki de en çok
dikkatimizi çekmesi gereken şey esasında
kozmozun bize evrenin simgelemesi ile
birlikte aynı zamanda belki de zaman ya
da mekan boyutlarıyla zihnimizin
algılamakta çok zorlandığı
bir anlamı bir düzeni ve uyumu
simgeliyor olması ve bizler de belki de
bu Kozmoz içerisinde bir toz bulutu
muamelesi yapabileceğimiz Dünyamız
içerisinde kendi anlam hakikat
arayışımız içerisindeyiz ve bu dünyadaki
maceramızın en başından beri esasında
kendi düzenimizi ve uyumumuzu İnşa
etmeye çalışıyoruz
bugün iddaa retorin yani hitabetin ya da
doğuda bilindiği şekliyle belagatin bu
düzeni ve uyumu inşa etmenin aslında tam
da merkezine oturduğu ile alakalı
Retorik dediğimiz zaman belki de
sizlerin Daha ziyade hitabet olarak
duyduğu ya da belagat olarak da
karşılaştığı kavram esasında daha çok
sözlü ikna yöntemleri ile
karşımızdaki dinleyicinin zihninde bir
etki oluşturabilmek onun düşüncelerine
etki edebilmek ve onu arzuladığımız
istediğimiz bir yönde harekete geçirmeyi
amaçlayan bir ikna sanatında simgeliyor
ve biz her ne kadar buna bir ikna sanatı
desek de bu aslında çok paradoksal
ikilem yaratan bir şey haline de geliyor
Çünkü esasında doğduğumuz andan itibaren
belki de en sık tekrarladığımız iki tane
eylemin bileşeninden bahsediyoruz
düşünmek ve konuşmak
belki nefes almak bunlardan daha fazla
tekrarladığımız bir eğlendir Yani
aslında gündelik hayatımızın son derece
parçası olan bir şeyden bahsediyoruz ama
bir yandan da bunu bir sanat olarak
görüyoruz ki bazı insanların bu konuda
Bizden çok daha Yetkin çok daha
etkileyici konuşabileceklerine
inandığımız için ya da topluluk önünde
konuşmaktan
bazen
utanacağımız için Hata yapmaktan
korktuğumuz için ya da fikirlerimizi
yeterince güvenmediğimiz için
Bugün sizlerle esasında sorgulayacağımız
şey
retoriğin hangi bileşeninin daha fazla
ön plana çıkması gerekçe olacak ve
sizlerle retory'i tekrar anlamlandırmaya
çalışacağız Zira bir çoğunuz tarafından
aynı zamanda Retorik son derece
tehlikeli bir silah ya da araç olarak
dahi görülebilir Zira sizlerle bu
dünyada ki maceramızda geriye gitsek ve
bazı siyasi liderlerin bazı önemli
düşünürlerin returiyi Nasıl
kullandıklarını mesela incelesek olumlu
örneklerle karşılaşabileceğimiz gibi
Örneğin içinde yaşadıkları zamana ve
geleceğe son derece iyi katkılar sunmuş
ve insanlığımızı ileriye götürebilmiş
liderlerle karşılaşabileceğimiz gibi
birçoğumuzun Ortalama bir şekilde
evrensel bir ahlak kuralıyla çok kötü
adedeceği
bazı eylemlerinde aynı zamanda belli
dönemlerde çeşitli Retorik teknikleri
kullanılarak bizim açımızdan
sıradanlaştığını görebiliriz
Dolayısıyla Retorik bazen mantık
safsatalarına atominemlere ya da
manipülatif bazı unsurlara dayandığında
hem bizler için hem de toplumumuz için
son derece olumsuz sonuçlara da
ulaşabilir
esasında bu zıtlığın içerisinde yani bir
yandan bu kadar tekrarladığımız ve
gündelik hayatımızın parçası olan ama
bir yandan da belki de bizim için
özellikle liderlerimiz ve
yöneticilerimiz tarafından
kullanıldığında son derece tehlikeli
sonuçlara yol açabilecek
miyim böyle bir paradoksa sahip
olmasının sebebi de
ilk günahtan günümüze kadar
şunu söylüyor
esasında Siz her ne kadar Retorik
yöntemleriyle
bu kozmozun içerisindeki anlamlama
hakikate doğruya ulaşmak isteseniz dahi
gününün sonunda bu Beyhude bir çaba
karşılayamayacağınız bir
ve dolayısıyla da Retorik dediğimiz şey
Yalnızca sizin biçimsel öğeleri ön plana
çıkartmanız lazım
yani ses domuzu nasıl kullandınız Jesse
ümitlerinizi ne kadar kullanabildiğiniz
insanların sizi dinlerken ne kadar
etkileyici olduğunuzu düşün
ün dolayısıyla da Retorik sanatı
dediğimiz zaman odaklanmamız gereken şey
bu
ama diğer tarafta
şunu söylerler elektronik esasında bizim
anlam inşa etme ve anlam bulma
yolculuğumuzdaki
esasa ulaşmak için Yani asıl içeriye
asıl değerli olanı ulaşmak için daha
ziyade mantık sistemimize oturtmaya
çalıştığımız ve bu sayede de
düzenimizi uyumumuzu inşa etmeye ve
geliştirmeye çalıştığımız bir yöntem
olmalı ve biz de bugün Sizlerle
cevaplardan daha çok
soruları önemseyerek Aslında bu
mücadeleyi kimin kazanması gerektiğine
karar vereceğiz
burada
esasında gördüğünüz şey Antik Yunanda
benim en sevdiğim düşünürlerden
ailelerden bir tanesi olan Aristo'nun
benimsediği retorin 3 tane bileşen
Aristo retori ilk sistematikleştiren ve
bu mücadelenin içerisinde kendi
argümanları bağlamında da bu sistematiği
kullanan düşünülen bir tanesi ve diyor
ki returi temelde 3 tane bileşeni vardır
bunlar; ethos Patos ve logos bunların
neler olduğuna bakalım
ethos dediğimiz zaman daha ziyade
konuşmacının karakterinden bahsediyoruz
konuşmacının karakterini oluşturan
unsurlar
konuşmacının geçmişi nasıl bir geçmişten
geliyor yani iyi mi bilirdiniz
uzmanlık alanı hangi konuda uzmanı
giyimi kuşamı
Temiz pak gözü gözükme diye
işte bazen Sizlerin de belki de çok
önemseyeceği üzere ne kadar karizmatik
gözüküyor gibi daha ziyade biçimsel
öğeleri merkezine alan bir güreşe
ve aristo'yu görüyorsundur o dönemde
daha dinlemeye motive olduğunu insan
figürleri onlar diğer tarafta benim
havalı gözükmeye çalıştığımda fotoğrafı
görüyorsunuz Çünkü bugünkü dünyada da
gördüğünüz zaman Dinlemeye daha fazla
motive olduğunuz tipleme olarak takım
elbiseli işte bir kürsüsün arkasında
sizlere Karizmatik bir bakış atmaya
çalışan C bu şekilde sizlere mikrofonu
almaya çalıştığımızı
nihayetinde ethos
dediğimi bunun etkisine ne kadar
kaldığınızı ölçebilmelisiniz
birazdan bunu ölçmenizin neden önemli
olduğuna tekrar geleceğiz
Patos
Tamam tamam Patos tamam
bir gibi gözüküyor olabilir Size ama
nihayetinde ikinci ve önemli bir yaşam O
da şunu çok
Sağ ol dinleyicileri
Bak ne kadar etkili altına alabiliriz ve
dinleyicileri ikna edebilmek ve onlara
harekete geçirebilmek adına
onların duygularını ne kadar
etkileyebilir
Şimdi ne yapıyorsunuz
çeşitli hikayelere anekdotlara
başvurabilirsiniz onların duygularını
daha fazla etkileyecek Coşkun konuşmalar
yapmaya çalışabilirsiniz
ya da
empati yeteneklerini devreye sokabilecek
onlarla Belki de ortak noktalarınızı
eğer onlara karşı gelmek istiyorsanız
zıtlıklarınızı daha fazla vurguladığınız
bir yöntem Tercih edebilirsiniz
Dolayısıyla Patos dediğimiz zaman ise
kendimize Şu soruyu sormamız lazım
neden mesela YouTube'da Böyle bağıra
çağıra gaza getirmeye çalışan motivasyon
konuşmaları
duyguyu merkeze alalım çok fazla
dinleniyor ya da neden karizmatik ve
bağıra çağıra konuşan yeri geldiğinde
duygusal bir şekilde Şiiler okuyan
siyasi liderlere oy vermeye daha motive
esasında ulaşmak istediğimiz şey bu
Kozmoz yolculuğumuzda mantık
sistematiğimizde kullanarak
fikirin kendisi esasın kendisi anlamın
hakikatin kendisi dolayısıyla da günümüz
sonunda
retroliği düşünce sisteminin ön plana
çıktığı bir kavram olarak da bir yandan
aldıramamız gerekiyor
Zira Kozmoz dediğimiz Zaman
rastlantısallığın
sistemsizliğin Tersine yani düzeni ve
uyumu aynı zamanda işaret etmeye
çalışıyoruz
ve İşte logos tam olarak o düzeni ve
uyumu yakalamak için bizim mantık
sürecimizin devreye girmesine özellikle
vurgulayan ve bizi hakikate götürmeye
çalışan bir sistem Burada saat burnunun
bir alıntısını görüyorsunuz söylediği
şey Türkçeye çevirdiğimiz zaman gerçek
sizin için bir rahatlık için değildir Bu
özgürleşmek içindir ve bu aslında tedavi
edici bir ilaç değil Aksine bu bir
öldürücüdür Dolayısıyla logosu bir
anlamda bu şekilde
lazım hakikate ulaşabilmek için mevcut
dünyamızdaki bazı hakikatleri öldürmek
zorunda kalacaksınız Bunu neden yapmamız
gerektiğini konuşmanın ilerleyen
kısımlarında yine göreceksiniz
şimdi şu soruyu soralım kendimize
bütün dünyasında
Biz birilerine hitap ederken ya da
dinleyici pozisyonundayken bu üç
bileşenden hangisine daha fazla
önemsiyoruz
benim gözlemim
ethos ve patos'un logosa kıyasla daha
fazla önemsendiği yönünde
bunun çok net kanıtları olduğunu
düşünüyorum mesela büyük şirketler
tüketicilere etkilemek için
gerçekleştirdikleri reklam tanıtım
pazarlama materyallerinde genellikle bir
karakter inşasına yönelirler
ya da belli dönemlerde mesela bizlerin
duygularını harekete geçir
ebilme yeteneğimize
oynayabilecek reklamları inşa etmeye
çalışırlar aynı şey iş yerimizdeki ya da
siyasi düzenimizdeki siyasi liderler ya
da işlerimizdeki liderler için de
geçerli yine aynı şekilde kendi
ethoslarını ve patoslarını daha fazla
inşa etmeye eve harcadıklarına bunu siz
de yapıyor olabilirsiniz gündelik
hayatınızda belki bireysel
ilişkilerinizde dahil duygusal
ilişkinize dahi bunu yapıyor
lar ve dolayısıyla
da esas olandan ziyade hakikatten ziyade
biçimsel öğelere daha fazla
odaklandıklarını
soru şu Peki bu yanlış bir şey
bu soruyu cevaplayabilmek için size
başka bazı sorular soracağım
Biz liberal dünyasında en fazla
vurgulanan ve belki de sizin en çok
hoşunuza giden bazı varsayımları
incelediğimiz zaman
bireyin rasyonel olduğu
Dolayısıyla bireyin rasyonel bir şekilde
hareket ederek kendisi için mantıklı ve
faydalı sonuçlar doğurabilecek
tercihleri yapabileceği
ve bu yüzden de başkalarının
yönlendirmesi etkisi ya da manipülasyonu
Altında Kalmadan kendi hayatı için doğru
güzel tercihleri
yapabilir onlar size güzel geliyor değil
mi Yani bunların aksini söyleseydim ve
size deseydim ki siz Aslında ethos ve
patos'tan daha fazla etkilenerek kendi
hayatınızda daha ziyade biçimsel öğeleri
önemseyerek tercihi yapıyorsunuz
ve esasa içeriye odaklanıp onu
düşünmüyorsunuz
bu
iradenizi aşağılamak gibi hisset
tirebilir Nasıl yani Ben kendimle
alakalı doğru tercihleri yapamıyorum
ya da bu
Sizi düşünmeye de sevk ettirebilir bu
bilgi konuşmanın anlamı tam olarak
çünkü Bundan sonra Düşünmeniz gereken
şey bir yerde insanlara hitap ederken ya
da
pozisyonundayken
retoriğin hangi bileşeninden ne ölçüde
etki altında kaldığınızı
ölçümleyebilmek ve tercihlerinizi buna
göre yönlendirilmeli
Neyi tercih ettiğiniz zaman
ağdaki şeylerden vazgeçmiş olursunuz
dolayısıyla da
tercihlerimizi gerek bireysel düzlemde
gerek toplumsal düzlemde her zaman logos
üzerine inşa edebilmeye çalışmak Esasi
yakalayabilmek için aslında değer
bir başka şey
şimdi söyleyeceğim şey Belki size
Optimum gibi gelecek biraz yani kendinde
çalışıyormuş gibi gözükecek olabilirim
ama şöyle düşünün
şimdi
etosun ve patosunda önemsiz olduğunu
iddia etmiyorum
bunlar önemli
ancak iddiam
merkezine alınmalı ve ethos ve patos'tan
daha değerli bir
Tabii ki de ethos ve patos'unda bir
önemli olduğunu kabul ediyorum ancak
dikkat bunların önemi araçsal bir önemi
para gibi düşünebilirsiniz
bir paranın kendi başına bir değeri var
mı
Mesela bir paranın üzerine istediğim
kadar büyük bir sayı yazayım ya da o
parayı son derece fiziksel olarak çekici
hale getiren çok güzel kabartmalar
işlerin üstüne
o para değerli oldun mu bu sebeplerle
o parayı değerli kılan şey ne
satın Alım gücü değil mi size neler
satın aldırabilir ethos ve Patos tam
olarak böyle biçimsel öğeleri ile bizi
asıl satın almak istediğimiz şey olan
içeriye mantığa götürmeye çalışıyor
ama aslında satın almak istediğimiz şey
günün sonunda kararlarımızı vermemizde
daha fazla etkisi olması gereken şey
logosunun kendisi mantığımızın içeriğini
hakikatin kendisi
bu son derece sorgulanan da bir mevzu
tarihsel olarak zaten
ama bugünkü dünyayı şekillendirdiğimizde
asıl yapmamız gereken şey logosa tekrar
yolumuzu koymak
şimdi peki bunu nasıl yapabiliriz
bunun üzerine birazcık
konuşalım bence bunun en önemli
adımlarından bir tanesi kendi hakikat
arayışınıza gerek bireysel düzlemde
gerek toplumsal düzlemde çıkmanız
Bunun için de hakikatlerle karşılaşmaya
hazırlıklı olmanız lazım
psikolojik olarak
Bu da belli bireysel çatışmaları kendi
içimizde ya da belki de toplumumuzdaki
farklı kesimlerle çatışmaları
beraberinde getirecek
ve günün sonunda
kendi hakikatlerinizle yüzleşmek zorunda
kalacaksınız Belki de yani meşakkatli
bir yoldan bahsediyoruz burada
ama iddia şu bunlardan kaçınarak
hakikati bulabilmek ve kozmozumuzu
ileriye götürebilmek ne yazık ki mümkün
değil Zira isterseniz şunu da
yapabiliriz
biçimsel öğelere odaklanmaya devam
ederiz
tehlikeleri
Belki de kendi irademizi tam bir
yansıtamadığımız çeşitli tercihlerimiz
de hayatımızı yaşamaya devam ederiz
Dolayısıyla kendinize sormanız gereken
şey nasıl bir hayat yaşamak istediğiniz
Çünkü bu tamamen bu konuşmadan sonra
yapacağınız tercihlere bağlı
bunun için
eğitim sisteminden mesela başlamamız
gerekiyor
Çünkü Bizler ne yazık ki özellikle
ülkemizde
bireylerimizi düşünmeye tartışmaya merak
etmeye sorgulamaya açık bir şekilde
yetiştirmiyoruz
hatta bunun önünü tıkayabilecek
özdeyişlere dahi son derece sık
kullanabiliyoruz
Burada gördüğünüz şey
okuyamayacaksınız yani size hiçbir
anlamı gelmeyecek bunu ama
bu antik çağlardaki 7 Özgür sanatı
simgeleyen bir görsel
Retorik bu sanatlardan bir tanesi
Hatta şöyle bir ayrım var
gramer Retorik Ve mantık Trivium diye
adlandırdığımız ve bu sanatların ilk
etabını oluşturan kısım
ve siz Eğer ki trivium'da iyi bir eğitim
alamazsanız
quadrouyuma yani ikinci kısma sanatın
Gök biliminin geometrinin olduğu kısma
ilerleyemiyorsunuz Dolayısıyla antik
çağlarda bu sistem 7 özgü sanat sistemi
günümüz üniversite eğitiminin Belki de
of
bunların temelini oluşturmaktadır
Dolayısıyla esasında
insanlara antik çağlarda dahi ilk
öğretmeye çalıştığımız şey merak
etmelerine sorgulamalarını
tartışmalarını teşvik etmek olmuştur
bugünkü dünyadan ne yazık ki bundan
biraz daha uzaklaşıyoruz
ve biçimsel öğelere biraz daha
iki
hakikate ulaşmak konusunda ve
kozmozumuzu ileride götürmek konusunda
önümüzü ne yazık Dolayısıyla önce
toplumsal mühendisliğimizi ve Eğitim
sistemimize merakı tartışmaya esas olanı
mantığı merkeze alacak şekilde Dizayn
etmeliyiz
Örneğin aramızda Ebeveynler varsa
çocuklarınızda tartışmaktan
kaçınmamalısınız
onların size galip geleceğinden
korktuğunuz için
aranızda ebeveynleriyle kendi
fikirlerini
özgürlükler varsa
bunu sonu yok
ötelemenin sonu yok
istediğiniz hayatı yaşayamazsınız
tartışmak ve redat Çünkü hayatımızdaki
en temel ve bireysel tercihlerde dahi
geçerli İş hayatınızda aile yaşantınızda
duygusal ilişkilerinize dahil
Dolayısıyla bu çatışmaya bir noktada
girmeniz gerekecek
sisteminde bize bunu öğretmesi lazım
bir hikaye anlatayım size son kısımda
Ömer ayrımı biliyor musunuz
ismini En azından duymuşsunuz diye
tahmin ediyorum
Emin Mall Of'un bir kitabı var Semerkand
çok ünlüdür okumanızı tavsiye ederim O
kitabın bir kısmında
Ömer Hayyam'ın yolu
Semerkant'a düşer Ömer abi şöyle bir
insan
çok önemli bir İslam alimi kendi
zamanında fellosof yani felsefeci o
zamanlar fel
sefe Aslında onu tanıyan insanlar
tarafından son derece itibar edilen
hitabete returuyla kuvvetli olan bir
insan Ama bir yandan o Göçebe yaşantısı
içerisinde gittiği yerlerde de son
derece fikirleri düşünceleri sebebiyle
korkuluk olmakla sürekli olarak yahlanan
bir insan
semerkand'da yolu düştüğünde
o dönemde çok daha tutucu bir toplumsal
yapıya sahip olan semerkant'ta da Ömer
hayyam'ı zındık olmakta dinsiz olmakla
suçlamışlar ve onun düşüncelerine ulu
orta toplumda dile getirmesinin önüne
geçmeye çalışmışlar
o dönemin Semerkant Kadısı Ebu Tahir
ona bir boş bir kitap hediye etmiş
ve demiş ki ne zaman
düşüncelerin böyle ağzına dökülecek gibi
olsa
onları bu boş deftere yaz kendine sakla
ulu orta dışarıya söyleme
beni hatırla kendini sakinleştir
ve bu defteri kullan
Ömer hayyamın en önemli eserlerinden bir
tanesi onlar rubaiyatı
bu şekilde ortaya çıkmıştır
bunu çok faydalı bir tercih olarak
bulabilirsiniz
ki yani adam doğrusunu yapmış yani Ömer
miydi o dönemde söyledikleri
düşüncelerden dolayı
ama
dikkatli gerçeği değiştirmez o Gerçekte
şu
kozmoza anlamlandırma çabamızda Ömer
Hayyam'ın Belki de kozmozun çözebileceği
bazı sırlarının anahtarlarını çok daha
geç bir vakitte ulaştık
Ömer Hayyam onları ulu orta konuşmak
yerine
kendisine sakladığı kitabına yazmak
zorunda kaldığı için ya da Öyle hisset
Dolayısıyla
logosu Merkezi aldığımız bir dünyada ve
logosunuzu konuşmaktan kaçınmadığımız
bir dünyada
aslında
kozmozumuzu ileriye götürebilmek bu
çatışmacılık sayesinde çok daha Mümkün
olacak
Aksi halde
yeni Ömer hayyamların rubaiyatların
bundan Belki de yüzlerce binlerce yıl
sonra ancak ortaya çıkabildiği bir
kozmozda gelecek nesiller yaşıyor
olabilir
Zira
kozmozumuzu ileriye götürebilmenin tek
yöntemi
bu çatışmacılığı sorgulamayı merakı
takip etmek olacaktır teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]